[Music]
foreign
sexy [__] way to cut it Lee
just [__] cut it you didn't even do a
[__] Dragon
slowing nothing cut it I made nothing
what's happened you beautiful
[__] welcome to the Church of
What's Happening Now it's a beautiful
day to be alive [__] Thursday July
16th what can I tell you you got the
World by the [__] boss that's all I
can tell you right or wrong what did he
say it was it yesterday or today like
you have big balls and a neck brace I'm
showing up with a big dick on the neck
brace [__] just in case don't
get confused just in case you swallow
this [__] helmet your neck goes back
I got you covered you know what I'm
saying oh it's for her yeah who do you
[__] think the neck brace is forced
that's romantic unless your name is
[__] Chad or something like that or
[__] Corey okay something like that
you want to go hang out with the boys
you know what I'm saying that's it it's
[__] here it's July 16th you're
sitting around scratching look at what
he's scratching his head oh I got like
10 minutes left I'm ready 500 milligram
Anthony Dolores edible I give him a
little corner of the [__] oh it's
right at least 100 probably right yeah
you took a little [__] piece I had
two big pieces I gave you 30 milligrams
it's always 30 milligrams you should
have a line of Edibles and it's just
everything is 30 milligrams everything
everything is always done everything's
beautiful check it out it's a nice
little look she don't even put in the
bag first Auntie don't let us that's why
I love it is it chocolate death bomb you
could [__] throw this on Palestine I
wish they would
I'm [__] believable we're here with
queer we didn't do yesterday because I
had the uh
fight companion so what's the [__]
difference I'm gonna do part two
podcasts in one day if I want to kill
myself let's spread them up I hope you
enjoy them a lot of people mad at me all
the time like getting talked you were
all high I wasn't either
when you're in a room with two [__]
got one guy that's a commentator and one
is a fighter what am I going to say
about a fight what am I gonna throw my
two cents in my stupidity in that's
where you go back to [__] trains
playing the Automobiles and you go back
to Steve Martin what could Steve Martin
have done in the president's junk candy
really got squished what was he gonna
say so all you could do it through his
little body language there's a couple
people that caught it they were like hey
man you like Muhammad Ali Europa dope a
[__] and you just throw a punch when
you need to and that's what I like
they're doing in that present you have
to know when to strike unless then you
become too overbearing so I don't want
people to think I was too [__] stoned
or whatever I don't like podcasts when
you have four people trying to talk yeah
you know they're they're a conjunction
type podcast it's fun for a while but
it's different but I want people to
understand where you stand in that if
you're in a room if you're doing a
basketball podcast and you got Julia
serving and Magic Johnson on the [__]
table what what stupidity are you gonna
add to this yeah what stupidity could I
possibly add to that table I could add a
little color do it so please it's not
that I was stoned or I was just trying
to be quiet I was just listening and
watching painting so there's some good
fights and you know what
uh and it's not even just because you
were on it but I watched the for like I
watched the full fights with the fight
companion that's a pretty cool way to
watch a fight I mean it's not as
in-depth as when Rogan's on like the
pay-per-view but it was interesting well
they go on other tangents yeah you know
which is always good too
but uh Hey listen man whatever to make a
anything that helps you that makes a
performance interesting yeah I knew it
was going to come down to that one of my
friends told me TJ said that Rogan
should start a podcast where he
commentates along with the with the UFC
or whatever the [__] it is I could see
the UFC going to it because I'm sure
there's a lot of fans who and and just
because I didn't hear them because I had
the podcast up I'm sure the commentators
last night did a great job but when you
have Rogan doing it for so long you have
people who are really loyal to him and I
could see since everything's on the
Internet is heading towards being on the
internet [__] it you have three choices
of commentators if if you don't like the
ones we have for free Rogan's on here
for an extra Buck or or a [__] they
haven't they have another UFC fighter on
there on a different one they could
probably have three or four teams it'd
be interesting very intelligent that's
uh
I never looked at I had a great time you
know it was the first time I met Brendan
Schwab hell of a nice guy you know it's
amazing that
three of my friends are 26 years old and
I've been thinking about that all night
he's 26. yeah oh he'll be a baby too
right he said look him up I can't turn
on his computer but I don't have a
[__] company
but it's just really weird that you guys
are uh
or 26 years old we got into that
conversation a little bit on Monday
where I was saying that I've been
thinking a lot about that lately how I
had nothing zero
zero going on at 26 at 26 I was coming
out of [__] prison
and the only reason why I had the things
I had was because the girl I was with it
wasn't because I was I was like I said I
was making seven thousand a month before
I went to prison and having a hard time
paying rent
like I would have to hide from the
landlord for [__] three days because
I didn't have the money to pay rent I
always had to get an advance from my job
that's how [__] up my money situation
was that I was I knew how to pay rent
and I knew how to pay bills and
everything I just didn't want to pay him
you know I didn't want to pay anything
on time I had did I have a credit card
then yeah yeah I had a Visa with like a
500 limit that I paid you know yeah how
old is he he's 31. yeah very close close
yeah five years away 31 26 it's it's
it's really [__] no difference but
it's amazing and I I that day that you
uh had mentioned it that I had spoken to
you about it I went home and I was like
wow
Lee and the Augustine and all these
young guys at least they know what the
[__] they want to do with 26 they're in
the ball game you know
uh I bumped into somebody at the airport
the other day
we're bullshitting and he asked me a
question he goes
that he didn't he felt really bad about
asking anybody else this you ready for
this what he said to me what do you when
do you realize you're going to leave
your house
did you before you went to college did
you think you were leaving Boston
yeah you knew that already did you want
to go away for college well I uh I that
was maybe one of the mistakes I made I
went to a school in Boston because it
was a good film school I didn't I didn't
particularly enjoy it I kind of wish I
went to uh
Drexel in Philly even though it wasn't
as good of a program just to get out of
Boston but it's a little bit different
for me because I went to film school so
the only places you can go really are
New York and LA so it wasn't really even
a choice there's some people who stay in
Boston but and and and and good for them
but they don't really end up doing
anything how old were you when you knew
you were going to leave Boston honestly
honestly when was the first time
it crossed your mind
I don't know about leaving Boston I
don't I don't remember that thought but
the joke in my family is that since I
was two I wanted a job an apartment and
a car I've always wanted just to be
older and out I've never and I had a
great childhood but it's just I've
always wanted to be out and on my own
and it's a
it's just luckily I mean for me I'm I
feel lucky that it was easy or for me
what were the reasonings of you wanting
to leave your hometown I mean you're a
nice kid
you never got arrested you have no
warrants no drug problems I mean what
was the reason did you think there was
more out there did you think that
yeah I was bored in my hometown and it's
a great place to raise kids but
there's like there's there was nothing
to do there's a blockbuster there's no
power there's no like you said you could
hop on a bus to New York to get on a bus
I would have had to go on like 30 or 40
minutes down the road there's nothing
where I grew up so how far are you from
downtown Boston 30 40 minutes
examine it wasn't that far but it's just
there's nothing and if you don't when I
turned 16 maybe that's probably one
because when I could start driving
and I could go into the City and go do
stuff that was probably around the age
when I knew I was gonna leave because
when I was in San Jose I went to
Original Joe's for breakfast
not at the airport
they're having a San Jose Airport
and some guy came only because I
listened to the podcast I had a couple
few uh situations this week I had that
situation where
he came up to me he was going to ask you
a personal question I didn't know what
the [__] was
at eight in the morning and he goes when
did you know you wanted to leave your
hometown
and I thought about it for a few days
I'm gonna give you the reasonings
I never thought I was going to leave New
Jersey or New York I didn't know
something else existed I had been to
California
I'd been to Miami and Florida I'd been
to Puerto Rico you know I had been to
Michigan for a bitty basketball
tournament I'd been to up and down the
East Coast driving back and forth to
Miami as a kid you know I'm doing making
that run with family or whatever
I never knew what life was like I'm not
gonna lie to you and tell you I had been
out here with my uncle and I remember
the rocks and the beach
and uh Dodger Stadium but not enough to
make me want to leave nothing was enough
to make me want to leave right yeah New
York I can't imagine wanting to leave no
then after my mom died oh I started
looking around and like no no even then
I didn't think so really one day I was
talking to Jimmy Bender the first family
I moved in after my mom died and I asked
Jimmy there was a trucking company named
Florida in Texas
no no it was just a trucking company
Florida Texas Freight or something like
that it was called when I was a kid I
still think they're around Florida Texas
Texas Florida or something like that and
I said it to him I go Mr Bender do you
think I gotta go work
at Texas flying out of Florida Texas and
he goes you can do whatever the [__] you
want he goes it's an interesting
question he always because he didn't
hear the whole question he goes I always
thought my one of my sons or my daughter
would leave he goes none of them ever
left he goes but it'd be great just to
go look outside the country because I
never thought about it let me look at
him going no Florida Texas the tucking
company goes yeah you could do whatever
you want to do but he had already said
that to me yeah you know so I remember
thinking about it and then that's that
was the it there's always a silver
lining and I figured out 30 years later
when I robbed that jewelry store when I
was a kid and the cops were looking for
me I had to go to Sarasota Florida for
four weeks yeah
and it's it's knowing without once you
know you can live without something you
don't know you never know you never know
like before I went to prison I'm like oh
no read for in prison I'm not gonna make
it and after the third night of no
reefer that's it I adjusted there was no
sense in crying there was no sense of
yelling or talking about it nothing
could help we'd grow through the [__]
prison wall so what the f you know what
I'm saying once you realize you can live
without something
it's like people always break up after
somebody takes a vacation or something
because once they realize I don't really
[__] miss you I didn't really [__]
think about you in fact I was happy you
weren't around that makes sense you know
I'm very happy that you weren't around
once people realize that they could do
without something it was like he ate
half of that 750 milligram bar
and I went home my plan was I only slept
four [__] hours last night so my plan
was to when the podcast one kaputs I was
gonna go home eat something play with
the baby till nine then take a nap I
hung out with the baby like I always do
I watch those ABC videos and all that
[__] and uh the wheels on the bus go
round then round the doors click click
click I watched all that what I played
with and at nine o'clock I went in me
and gray I grabbed gray and I said great
we're taking a [__] nap [__]
and I finally popped my head up at 10 to
10. I couldn't fall asleep I got out I
wrote the end of a chapter I sent some
emails
I got aggravated you know me though it
was a beautiful [__] day to be alive
then you called me what happened oh
[__] so that candy didn't work on you
a little bit but not really it didn't
take it wasn't as good as a half agumi
no no not God those goomies
okay no as long as I know but I was just
I thought I was gonna get high because
it started to kick in and I was driving
home from here because I had a piece of
equipment at my house
so I went I was driving home on more
Park which it's this really small Street
and right at Laurel Canyon this cop
pulled up next to me and his side view
mirror hit mine I just on the left-hand
side all right I'm on driver's side
so I was like [__] and it wasn't me I
was stopped and he just hit it and I
just like I froze it was a red light and
he he stopped and when the green light
came up I kind of pulled up but I was
like I think it's okay you guys and they
were like pull over we'll just make sure
I was like [__]
so I pulled up into a little uh strip
market I got out and if it had been
broken I probably would have said let's
just go because I didn't I didn't want
to be high [__] anxiety attack
paperwork so I like I just looked there
was nothing wrong with it
um
but they like I just left and I got
paranoid but you didn't get to get out
of jail free card nothing all these
[__] I should have done you gotta do
something all I imagined was already
yelling at TSA I was like would he
[__] yelled to these guys but I saw
some I saw a video tonight of like kids
at a bar yelling at cops who were
arresting their friends and cops don't
[__] around anymore this guy this cop
tackled a kid and I was like holy [__]
so I was like no I'm just gonna get out
of here somebody put a video of a deer
getting shot by a cop there why do
people post those [__] videos at
night what is the inside that some idiot
months ago posted the [__] zebra
getting killed by the [__] giraffe I
don't get what P I don't like that [__]
I don't want to see nobody suffering you
know you know who's the worst and she's
she's a great she Melissa Eva Perez from
San Jose yeah
every day on Facebook two kids kidnapped
and burned and it's like no yeah
I'm like why are you posting that stuff
but it's just uh it was a crazy day but
if I go right back now we're back I'm
sorry about the audio until that [__]
[__] happens you know what I'm saying
I mean I can't control it I didn't get
any [__] what is unbelievable no I'm
straight but it was uh yeah I went home
my knee is [__] up I put ice on it
when I went home when I woke up I put
level elevated and then about one
o'clock I got bored to death about 12 30
In The Heat Of The Sun I went outside
and started doing kettlebell swings ugh
just sweating and I [__] started is
that okay for your knee cleans you know
what man I gotta do something to move
the blood around because I I walking
hurts a little bit and I was still
hitting the bag at the Y I just didn't
want to lose my parking spot these
[__] bought my house notorious
dog I'm [__] anti-anxiety I am
anxiety written over my parking lot I
would rather sit home and eat nothing my
[__] car and lose that parking spot I
hold on to that mother that's how you
know you're getting [__] old oh yeah
when I'm doing two things lately that
are just embarrassing to even talk about
but I'm like what else he's doing I'm
doing not leaving the house because I
don't want to lose my parking spot yeah
in front of the house I like that spot
in front of the house I would kill a
[__] for that too but I will
walk to the bodega and get like you know
stupid [__] so I don't have to leave the
house I got enough food at the house
and I'm stealing sweetness
from [__] restaurants when I go on
the road you put them in a little napkin
in case they break my [__] pocket
it is the weirdest thing because every
coffee every [__] hotel room I go
down the road has a [__] egg or a
[__] coffee machine but it's only
like two sugars and stuff they give you
two [__] sugars like you're sitting
there trying to drink coffee watching
Law and Order and there's no [__]
sugar so now you got to call room
service they won't open the door because
you got no do not disturb so it takes
them 20 minutes they go right back
downstairs and call you hi you do not
disturb son is on then you come back
down by the time I put the [__] thing
in the coffee's goddamn cold so what was
the point of it I just got aggravated
yeah that's what I think I got a box of
[__] sweet little at the house do you
think I put it in my suitcase [__] no I
leave it at home every goddamn week and
then I go on the road and I realize at
[__] 12 o'clock I need a little
coffee because I like drinking coffee at
night one cup before I go to bed I sleep
like a [__] Soldier nice because it
takes me up and then right down I crash
Babu okay you follow no problem that's
the old school mental it's cocaine days
yeah well what goes up must come down
[__] he says when I was testing
the audio and water box are called just
because I was bored I didn't want to
talk to it to myself and he was telling
me a good way because I was like he was
telling me how he does the Edibles and
he goes out I'm like how do you do it he
says he drinks like an energy drink
right after he eats the edible so it's
like it's like a a heroine brings down
cocaine brings you up it's like a little
mix so that's how he walks around
that's good for him I don't know the
water bottle and jump up do they call
the podcast he just called me I was just
testing the audio he wanted to see what
was crack-a-lacking yeah I put it up on
Twitter but something weird happened
today uh
I I was never really emotional
but as I get older I want to hear what
you have to say about 25 what older
about what I don't know I'm older that's
what everyone says everyone says I'm
young but I feel old
um
the the Boston bomb I think they had all
the videos today of the marathon I
started getting teary-eyed I wasn't
there for it but just seeing the
pictures and the people hugging like you
weren't in New York for 9 11.
but how did that affect you I was pissed
really
I didn't get pissed that morning I was
pissed later on because uh I know what
it does to people those people that were
walking around that day
you know I got pissed when I heard the
stories and I'm taking the ferry over
like that was just [__] Frozen I
can't imagine being at the Boston
Marathon last year that was one of the
most thoughtless [__] things who
knows why they did it who the [__] knows
these people nowadays man yeah who the
[__] knows
I did stupid [__] when I was 21. I would
never think of doing something like that
for kicks but who knows what their
motives were and uh
whatever and they have a Sean NG
whatever Discovery National Geographic
about them getting caught did you see it
no I didn't see it pretty [__]
interesting and how they they shot the
kid and blah blah blah and the other kid
went into a [__] boat and hidden uh
how the pictures they they the FBI saw
the pictures and when the bomb went off
those two didn't move yeah that's how
they knew it was them it was very
interesting how the FBI catches you and
now you know man we got [__] cameras
everywhere the cameras everywhere you
have to assume there's a camera watching
you at all times even a black and white
little [__] porno camera that won't
see a deck of your hair but it sees you
and they'll [__] show you in court
you know some guy will come in and clear
it up in [__] court so
who the hell knows Lee I I just my heart
goes out so the Boston Marathon was
today correct yeah it was today and you
know what I'm gonna piss some people off
but and tell me if I'm wrong tell me but
just seeing all those people out there
and something I don't see out here I
don't know what it is but east coast
people in the towns like there was so
much pride for Boston
and I just it made me it made me like I
started tearing up and I just made
I don't feel that out here for people
from this city
so maybe I'm wrong maybe I just don't
don't interact with it it's an empty
City man
yeah I have a lot of problems with this
city I have a lot of problem with
friendships in this city and how they
work how everything is to let people
know that they know you after that
there's no friendship there's no
friendship you know uh when I grew up
those were friends I had around me those
[__] I could count them for
anything I had a great time with them
when I went out you know when I went out
I had a good time with them from the
heart here I see people for a few hours
and I feel their [__] death
I feel because maybe things aren't going
their way I I when I'm around people who
sold their [__] soul
I leave them and I leave I feel like
[__] for three or four [__] days
people sell their [__] Souls that's
the people you [__] people clap for
and cheer for and jump up and down for
these people sold their souls you're
like Joey what do you mean the devil
showed up with a pen no no somewhere
along the line they over they ignored
something something natural that comes
over you because they thought what they
were doing is is completely better than
what somebody like you uh somebody at
home is doing you know they have this
heir to them that they're better than
everybody because they have three
dollars or because they're on TV or
because they've done a movie and I never
understood that for me it's always been
about the job for me it's not because
I'm about anybody I'm like that I'm not
even close to doing that [__] but I I
just that's what I don't like about it
and that's why when you go to a Dodger
game people leave in the sixth [__]
inning you know that's the big knock
about the Dodge against and yeah parking
is hard I'm walking out of his heart but
it's like that their uh Johnny come
lately fans there's a word for those
type of people
it's like after the Boston Red Sox won
the Boston Red Sox hat now is [__] as
big as the Yankee hat maybe you know
because everybody wants to wear Boston
for years when they were losing nobody
won Boston Red Sox hat you understand me
uh it's amazing the Loyalty that we have
here we have no loyalty like I said it's
between me getting a job but you getting
the job I'm bad my [__] Lee to get
the job even though I've known you for
15 [__] years you know yeah I I look
at this town I can tell you I probably
have four close friends you know and
you're one of them you know what I'm
saying Ari I mean that that the rest are
just [__] acquaintances because I
know I look at somebody and I know if I
ever gotten a beef and I had to call
them to bail me out the cash wouldn't be
there they'd hang up and make up a story
how they couldn't get the ATM card
didn't work and then I would look at
them weird I would never look at them
the same way so that's why I don't even
put them close to me I know these people
aren't worth their weight in gold it's
[__] crazy but there's a dude in the
background of every shot just like not
in his head and I could do that that's
what black people do like no he's white
he's a white dude whatever he's confused
you know what I'm saying I'm so glad you
brought it up how how amazing does it
feel putting powder on your nuts I love
it it's the best feeling I don't need it
as much anymore I've lost a little bit
of weight but I still I still have
powder oh you're rough against the jeans
and [__] you don't make that noise it's
[__] Monday it's a beautiful day to
be alive we're back it's the second week
of the year you know what the [__] what
do you need all they need is you just
looking on Twitter five people got shot
at a Chris Brown concert when the [__]
are you people gonna realize stay the
[__] away from that kiss of death
because that's exactly what that
[__] is he was at my gym for a
second but he's the kiss of that yeah
how the [__] building didn't blow up
is beyond me five people Chris Brown
just has this [__] thing even when I
see him I'm like that guy I don't know
what the [__] his deal is you know again
five I don't know what the [__] the
story is but if you bring why would you
bring a gun to a Chris Brown concert
unless you're gonna shoot him that's
what I'm gonna shoot is [__] Chris
Brown right in the [__] neck what the
[__] it's Monday you know what I'm
saying you gotta start the week off good
I'm not as well
right in that [__] tattoo and stupid
[__] like
what's happening You Beautiful People
had a great time Saturday night you came
to the Melrose Improv thank you very
much we had a great time Lee was there
with the girlfriend uh people there yeah
Einstein from 10th Planet Culver City uh
my man uh what the [__] his name all
the Renee was there
uh who else was [__] I mean all
different 10 Planet Van Nuys oh he was
there Hassan
from GMAC I mean there was just some
[__] Renee and Carson he's probably
at Disneyland yesterday so it was
raining he flew in from New York with a
girl he's just like [__] I'm gonna take
a vacation yeah that's how you do it and
then didn't someone else come from like
Australia and then England there was
some people there so it was cool I got
stoned as [__] I ate some Stars we need
to start David this morning did you eat
it of course I did [__] me I was
watching you watch me
like until until I stopped chilling you
like you're you're watching me but
you're not watching me I gotta watch
you're like oh [__] you know uh
when I do these shows now I feel
different you know on stage and I feel
different when I'm there and I gotta
tell you something it's a good time for
comedy right now
it's a very good time for comedy if you
live in the LA area and you've stopped
by The Comedy Store it's a good time for
[__] comedy you know at the Improv
the other night it's a good time for
comedy when I'm at the Laugh Factory
it's a great time for comedy you know uh
it's something's different it's like the
good guys won finally you're not
watching the [__] that Comedy Central
puts out and all these other [__]
stations but uh you know Network you're
watching the underground [__] come out
now the [__] that people wouldn't talk
about and it's off through Twitter and
social media and it's coming out on the
network now like little Esther was just
on TV they have Ari's on TV next Friday
tell you something man
right now the funniest guy working is
Sebastian Maniscalco I haven't seen
anything a tight close second is Ari
shafia I'm telling you this right now
guys I'm not telling you because my
friend I'm telling you that meant the
material that's already strong right now
about Biggie and going to China and
taking a [__] it's some of the funniest
[__] I've ever heard in stand up and I'm
not telling you guys this is the he's my
buddy I love him to death but I'm really
proud of him he tore it up in Las Vegas
that night with Rogan I was sitting
there going what the [__] am I going to
come up with
because this guy's killing him he was I
don't kill him killing them killing them
killing him so you know Bill Burr is out
there now I mean it's just so he's
special for me it's Friday night are we
yeah I think you can buy it pretty soon
on his website okay but yeah you could
he said something crazy like he he shot
like 70 minutes and only 40 Something's
Gonna Get on TV so for five bucks I'm
just gonna go and buy it and get the
whole 70. it's Friday night on Comedy
Central
yeah I think it's the 11th or 12th and
it's like that night at midnight so it's
like tonight Saturday morning no no it's
not the 12th and it's Friday okay it's
Friday the 16th yeah let me check and
the 17th we're doing
the uh riot I like Riot Comedy Festival
right and I'm doing the show Saturday
night with our magical I think TJ
millinari
and it's called Revenge the theme is
Revenge which is [__] perfect for me
and then this show comes out that you're
on when this deck the following Thursday
night what well the whole season started
it's like eight weeks I think right I'm
on the last one oh really yeah I'm in
the last oh cool I'm like a [__]
April or something like that but I don't
give a [__] Hey listen man no for our
Comedy Central does not even look at me
for Ari to go to the bathroom me with
Comedy Central I own my [__] life you
know that's a type of kid he is he just
told him from the jump he's doing it
because he was there from the beginning
so it's the 16th yeah you gotta admire
that because the 17th we're doing a riot
Festival whatever the [__] it is do you
think uh
do you do you wish you had been on
Comedy Central
yes and no I just didn't like the fact
how they shunned me from the beginning
but listen man that's the beauty of Life
some people like you and some people
don't like I never really it made me
work in a different direction I I at
least I knew that door was closed to me
I don't want to live my life going ah
Maybe
you know at least I knew that they
didn't want to do business with me it
all started when Joe did the man show
and I came out naked running
they all banned me for that they kind of
like it was like a silent type band yeah
and years later they took a couple
comedy pictures from me they called me
in for a few comedy pitches
and then uh my name's been thrown around
for specials or whatever involvement on
midnight and stuff like that and they
just said no you know flat out so you
know I hear everything yeah I hear
everything even when they're working
again you know this chapter on this
thing of Revenge when already called me
because they're doing this it was really
weird because it's going on in a weird
part of my life I'm trying to write this
book and I'm writing a book about the
rocket ship when I lived in that rocket
ship in 84.
and I didn't know until I was writing
the chapter about living in a rocket
ship and 84 on the way here I made a
left and I went down that alley and I
saw a guy sleeping that's next to a
shopping cart yeah and I I kept going
like I wonder what if you know I I said
to myself I wonder what it feels like
tonight to sleep all the time I go you
know what
I slept outside many a [__] night I
slept outside in the car here in L.A for
about three or four or five months
and an 84. do you get any sleep when
you're sleeping outside I can't imagine
you get any sleep
it depends how [__] up you are I see
you ever been walking you just see a guy
like dropped yeah and you gotta walk
over him like that guy just got tired
and fell like that guy just said [__] it
you know yeah you sleep you sleep with
one eye you got money in your pocket you
don't know if somebody's gonna run up to
you and stab you while you're sleeping
you know if I'm walking down the street
and I'm gonna kill her and I'm not gonna
kill somebody I see a bum I'm gonna
shoot him right in the [__] foot you
know something he's sleeping you know
there's no resistance if I'm a [__]
psychotic person you know
laughs and it just sleeping outside just
does something to you you sleep a few
hours you sleep like I slept outside
when I was a comedian you know many a
night I had to take a bus somewhere and
there's a four hour delay what are you
gonna do
hey you gotta [__] sleep you sit in
the bus station you put your jacket on
over your head you put your money in
your front pocket and you put your hand
in there and you put the bag next to you
and try your best yeah but that has to
be a difference between my buses coming
in four hours and I got nowhere to go oh
I laughed so [__] lutely yeah
absolutely you have nowhere to go in you
you know you wait for the heat from the
sunlight I mean I remember being on that
[__] rocket ship and doing coke in
there like it's a a three foot you know
someone posted a picture of it I thought
it was I thought it was horizontal it's
vertical it's vertical okay and it has a
couple different floors and it has a
beam in the middle and that's how you
get to the top
I would just chill in the middle floor
just in case I had a pee or I'd pee off
the railing
or whatever but you had to snorting a
three feet I would actually go in there
with booze by myself at night and then I
would hide like a blanket and you know
I'd do dumb [__] you know
but I know what it's like to be outside
and it was November in December in
Jersey that means there's snow there's
snow it's [__] cold up
so I thought about the rocket ship
you know I wrote it I wrote a general
thing living in a rocket shipment I go
this nobody wants to read this you have
to describe what you were going through
what it felt like at the end of the
night to not only come down off the coke
and get the Press but then you're
naturally depressed you're living in a
[__] rocket ship yeah you know the
weight of everything was on top of me
but on that weight was a a pain that I
had had like I was 21. and
I was just sick and tired sometimes
people just get sick and tired and I
always know I want to leave Jersey so I
came out here to see my uncle
and I came out to to get you know listen
life throws curveballs at you
and then people throw a curveball at you
but you know your family's always going
to be there
you know this last Thanksgiving
I've been talking to my uncle since 2009
and this last Thanksgiving we were going
to get together
and do Thanksgiving we hit him on the
podcast we had him on the podcast and
the Monday before Thanksgiving my cousin
called and she said hey he doesn't want
to do it he wants to go to a restaurant
and in a way it helped me out because it
got me off the hook I didn't want to
bring the baby down with the turkey in
the car and all that so I started
thinking Michael you know what this is
perfect
so he called Mexico he goes no I didn't
say that so I said to him listen what
I'll do is this we're gonna go into
turkey we'll eat here we'll see what
you're doing later on if you don't want
to go out with your girlfriend or your
son we'll bring some food down to you
well I call them that Danny goes no my
son's here I'm gonna be all right but if
you want to stop down later that's fine
too with the baby I go all right
so that was the week I had the the
vertigo so we went out we took the baby
out I went back home and I fell asleep I
had very I laid down on it I called the
next day he didn't answer the phone he
didn't call me back I called him a
couple times they didn't call me back
which meant he was pissed off at me
Christmas Eve we get invited to my
cousin's house his son's house he's
there
and we're cool but we're not usual cool
he's not saying much to me so I can tell
he's pissed off over Thanksgiving which
he he should have told me directly
instead of telling his daughter he
should have told me what was on his mind
instead of mentioning it to his daughter
that his daughter told me and I just you
know when somebody lets you off the hook
then let you off the [__] oh you'd have
to be there Sunday at 6 30 you're like
fine often they call you back and I'll
let him go no no we switched it to 6 30.
[__] you I already made plans [__] you
know so old school tonight [__] the
guests pull you [__] we're going
straight up tonight old school checking
with you guys it's been a while we've
had a lot of great guests from Sarah
Tiana to Rich Franklin to Joe Rogan to
Gabriel to Ralphie do you see what
Gabriel was doing it's like a week in
one Theater in Chicago did like 20 000
seats oh please he [__] kills in
there then he comes here he does three
nights somewhere in Anaheim and then two
nights then he's off for [__] New
Year's and it's over if I get out of
work early tomorrow we'll go to his
Christmas party let's make another work
girl I don't know what time again it's
supposed to rain here and then like if
you guys don't know when it rains in L.A
everything goes [__] Cabana
so if you got to leave for work and be
there at eight usually leave at seven
you gotta leave at like 5 45 minutes
of your [__] guys it's a sad truth
they fall the [__] apart when you live
in Colorado and it snows it's amazing
how it didn't affect them at all like
snow was just another day for those
people like it snowed a foot people
still on time at work you know when you
live in New York when I lived in New
York back in the 80s and it would snow
the city would shut down this is a huge
Metropolitan City with so many things
available to it
excuse me the city would shut down then
a small town like Aspen Colorado
it snows the foot and it's gone in two
[__] hours my mom calls me a wimp now
she called me the whole week because I
said it was like cold it was chilly like
55 degrees and she's coming from Boston
and she's like you're such a wimp now oh
no this is it was cold in the [__]
mornings listen you're talking to a guy
that used to [__] bathe in this 40
degrees now I get out of the shower when
I yell at my wife when I'm putting the
heat on like take the [__] she puts them
on for a little while and she turns it
off she goes it gets too hot in here too
quick but if you turn it off when I come
out of the shower it's freezing I like
opening the door and that bust the heat
hits you and it drives you off the last
couple spots you haven't uh you know
[__] dried off
but it gets uh you're not used to the
weather you're not used to the cold
weather no more but last week we had
rain Friday very very ran a few days
last week the big storm was Friday and
that was the day for some reason I
didn't have to be at work till seven but
I got up like at 4 30 because in my
sleep I was worried about the rain yeah
they said they're gonna call work for
the movie the next day
and they pushed it back but we still
worked and it cleared up but they were
scaring [__] white people
scaring them don't go to work the 91 is
backed up you know how long it took me
to get to Simi Valley 20 [__] minutes
yeah with the rain I got the Subaru I
kicked that [__] where it's
always four-wheel drive and if it hits a
puddle the other time it picks it up
that's how the Subaru engineering works
it just picks it up where a tire if it's
hydroplanes or something I got to I got
to the [__] set in 20 minutes I
couldn't believe it they were scaring
[__] Gentiles to death on TV we don't
think we talked about it why did you
decide not to get like a Cadillac
oh
I've never been big I I don't like how
in La everybody judges you by your car
yeah it really bothers the [__] out of
me I was telling my mom a lot of people
here have like Porsches and BMW and
studio apartment everybody has a series
three BMW here yeah uh you know if you
see anybody in the industry a junior
agent and then as they get there for a
while they get a 5 Series
I listen I'm not here to impress anybody
I'm here to impress myself you know I
like the Subaru I like feeling safe
I like knowing that if it rains I could
think a Cadillac's a great car and
whatever but
I can't pay three to four hundred a
month and and not sleep at night if
something does break down I've always
had great success with Subarus and
Toyotas why would I want to change it
now at this point yeah if I start making
an abundance of [__] money and my
second car would be a Cadillac or
something but then I gotta have a family
so I can't be
selfish you'd have to be like you know
you know what I'm saying plus with with
your daughter you don't want to have
like messes in the back of a Cadillac I
guess listen she can do whatever the
[__] she wants as long as I pay for the
car it's my [__] car you know and
they're gonna throw apples on the kids
are going to be kids yeah I went to the
park Saturday and there was a soccer
thing going on a soccer camp and it was
kids hurray a little older some kids
knew what the [__] was going on the
other kids would just do butts they were
just there out in the sun walking around
half [__] up there was a camp like two
euros and one for like four-year-olds
and I'm walking around I'm watching
those two-year-olds because I could see
if I could put her in here and my wife
and her battle it I'm like what's going
on she goes she wants to go down and go
don't let her [__] go down there
like well you're gonna sit there and
battle with him you got to pick your
battles with these kids she's going to
run down there anyway she's going to
walk around touch the net touch the ball
and then she's going to walk away from
those kids
no she's not I picked her up walked her
down that's exactly what she did she
kicked the ball she saw 20 kids she
looked around she goes I don't need this
[__] by myself she walked away but we
signed her up oh that's cool next
Saturday 11 o'clock yeah even though she
might not like it she'll like it it's
kicking the ball it's running around
falling in leaves they got two coaches
there they coach you they tell you what
to do you know she's mingling this is
what they're supposed to do so they grow
up with [__] social skills you you
know you gotta Wonder all this [__]
don't talk about cops and all this you
know when I was growing up cops are more
involved with you in the next
neighborhood that was the same cop
patrolling the same neighborhood he got
to know you if something went on he came
and saw you you talked to him he asked
you questions and now you have all these
complaints of cops and aggressive
behavior you know it's an excessive
force yeah excessive force whatever the
[__] they want to call it that's because
maybe they don't have the right social
skills we do live in a computer
generation yeah we're very computer
generated we're not when I used to
dealing with people we leave the house
scared if you watch the news everybody
is [__] fearful you know one good
thing about the church I was thinking
about this when I first got into the
church when I got into Beauty and the
Beast or the church
it wasn't to expose Bigfoot it wasn't to
expose steroids it wasn't to expose
Hollywood people that are gay it wasn't
exposed to anything it was to expose
life's [__] that we get fed and
either you believe it
or you [__] don't and move on you
know and uh do you get nervous blow
because I went to the movies with my mom
today and for a second when they were
doing that thing like if you see any
suspicious people tell somebody for a
second I was like what would I do if a
gun A gunman came in here I'm here with
my mom when I'm by myself I don't really
worry about it but like do you worry
about it now when you're going out with
Mercy I worry about everything and
everything
and and you'd be an [__] if you would
you'd be an [__] if you won every day
you go on Twitter and there's an
explosion somewhere 14 people got killed
that guy in Australia the guy in
Australia every [__] day people you
get up every morning and if you have a
half a heartbeat
and you want an [__] like I am that
we actually look at that [__]
to start your morning we actually look
at that [__] to start your morning
because I do I'm guilty of it all right
I don't put the [__] news on and I
won't hear it visually but while I'm
streaming on Google or whatever the [__]
my first page is Yahoo you see what
happens you know 14 children get killed
in Africa whatever the [__] you you know
and it stays in Utah today I'm not
listening I'm not the type of guy that
would blame police officers for anything
I I know what life is on both sides of
the shield I've seen cops that are
stressed out and I've seen people that
are stressed out that just have a bad
day
I know one thing about life lead people
have bad days
you know there's a guy did you see that
he killed his wife put in a trunk of the
car and then took the three kids oh
Jesus no I showed his picture he's all
cracked up and [__] I mean
I I don't know a bad day for that I know
at this bad days that uh
people just leave the house and have a
weapon and they get out of a car and a
cappuccino
there's bad days did you ever fight with
the cops I know you dealt with them a
few times no no
I couldn't file a complaint against a
police officer because every time I've
had contact with a police officer I've
always pretty much been a gentleman
when I was a kid I got hit one time by a
cop with a stick and a big melee I was a
young kid like maybe in the seventh
grade really I don't remember it was the
night that we felt up that chick's
titties and [__] after that basketball
game there was a fight first on the
thing and a cop hit me and I didn't know
who it was and
I was wasn't mad at them I could have
been an [__] and made a big drama
because I always thought from his side
of the [__] thing this is a guy
that's just telling us to go and
you get hit with a stick but I've never
been ever assaulted before
I've always had good relationships with
cops like when they've arrested me I've
been cool because they're just doing
your your job or your job is to shut
your [__] mouth
and don't argue with him and don't tell
them that this is what really happened
don't say a [__] word that's the best
thing you could do yes no thank you
the handcuffs hurt they don't [__]
hurt but for me to sit here and say pig
suck and all that I can be that type of
guy I never have been they did a job
when they arrested me they did the best
job they could I can't lie to you I've
never really had yeah
because I go back and forth sometimes
like should I be protesting I don't like
I don't know like is this like is this
like an important thing to be doing but
I I have you ever protested before no
I just what are you gonna do you're
gonna get a stick with a [__] sign
and walk down there you would kill me if
I if you saw another stick
I lived in Boulder and I saw protesters
on the CIA would come to town
and they come to recruit on campus
I don't know if they recruited I took
applications or they spoke to applicants
or whatever the [__] and there was
always little Wars on there and these
kids would go down and then I figured
out who these kids were that
you know they were trust fund kids that
just wanted to get some form of
attention I got it you know and unless
you really believe look like I
I just it's not that I don't like
protesters and what they stand for is I
think that sometimes people are down
there protesting and they don't even
know what they're protesting for right
they're just protesting to make friends
it was like that thing I always made fun
of that thing that happened downtown
years ago some of the Wall Street yeah
the people who were going to shut down
the corporations but meanwhile they're
calling them mommies yeah on the iPhone
you know making videos and sending
Tweets out you're not
you're not shutting nobody down this is
what a complete shutdown is throwing all
that [__] away
you can't stand online on Apple for your
[__] phone and all that uh yeah
but you want something very interesting
that was the cop thing normally I never
I always knew they had a job when I was
a kid I was exposed to cops that came
and once a week got an envelope and that
was whether it was the bookie place in
the Bronx
for a long time when I went to Catholic
school on Saturdays I helped out this
other bookie jail
and they always had a relationship with
cops and it was a known thing then
listen we're going to do this for
business nobody's gonna hurt nobody's
getting [__] slap but not selling drugs
here
's an envelope just to make sure
everybody knows we're on the legit side
some people would judge me and say
that's the wrong you could never pay
that's not from the movies like they
would actually do that they would
actually have cops do you consider them
dirty cops
well there's [__] jerk-offs and this
gentleman
and that's an every [__] business
yeah
there's jerk offs and there's gentlemen
there's guys that come in and go Lee how
you doing my name is detective whatever
this is great that you have a new bar
here
and everything's fine here but from 12
to 5 the kid works at Joey Diaz he's a
known felon
I know he takes bookie
and I know that if somebody wants to get
a gun or maybe a kilo of Coke he could
arrange your front we can shut you down
right now I could call the ABC and shut
you down for employing this guy but I'm
not gonna do that
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna send
somebody in here once a week and give
him an envelope let's say what do you
pull out of here a week
let's say I'm real likely you pull out
thirteen thousand they're gonna say ten
thousand
and I go okay well he got me every week
we want 400 a week
all right that's one cop who comes in
shakes you down this is the old days I
don't know what happens today
this is what my mother had the bar
you're never gonna see that guy again
okay but every week a patrol guy's gonna
come in so let's say that guy came in no
then it's gonna be that's a a sheriff
okay then a city cops are coming oh no
he's only wanted 200 and you're going to
agree to that what's the story though
what the [__] you've been hiding all
weekend last time I saw you uh I gave
you a brown you're gonna eat with a
bunch of uptight [__] people
and that's why you gotta load up when
you go to eat hang out with people like
that it's okay you hang out with people
like that from time to time because they
make it seem how lucky you are for
hanging out with crazy people yeah I was
telling Steve and I don't remember if
I've said that on the podcast but
one of my favorite things about
podcasting is how cool like we get to
have these cool conversations that no
one has in regular life anymore
like I feel whenever I watch old movies
or TV shows I always watch because I've
basically forgotten what it's like to
live without a cell phone or Internet
like I I was 10 or 11 or something when
that started coming out but I honestly
don't remember
so I always look and see what people
used to do and a lot of it was just
hanging out talking like doing
activities
and that's what and I went to this thing
and they were all very nice but it was
supposed to be a birthday dinner and
maybe I was just high and paranoid but
it seemed like everyone was very quiet
so like I tried to produce the dinner
conversation
but uh I meet the birthday girl
and she goes oh and they were talking
like oh I was in Japan for two years I
was like oh were you there during the
earthquake and she got really sad and I
realized that after I asked him that it
might not be the best thing to bring up
on her birthday but I was like and she's
like yeah I was like um I must have said
[__] crazy like
I've always
every once in a while I have a friend
name advice into something I get them
like oh my god what have I done
they started talking about like I don't
even know this like they're talking
about you know when you try to
and the best thing to do is just shut
your mouth act civil giggle you know
smile you always bond with somebody
there's always some other nut in there
that you and him
I was the only guy there yeah oh no yeah
yeah that's even see you got yourself
you got to cut that [__] out too that's
something you got seriously was good but
yeah but it's one guy with five girls I
just know you gotta cut that [__] out
yeah it's a [__] you gotta avoid me a
lot you don't want to be cool I got lost
in the way from the train to the
restaurant because I was so high I
couldn't really understand what my phone
was started walking around downtown
and then it was scary on the way there
it was like that Star Wars when they go
into hyper speed or whatever and the
light and the lines keep going because
the train was going really fast and then
this homeless dude who was hammered and
he had his shoes off
and he was having a conversation with
himself and he was crying and laughing
and I had my headphones in because I was
just trying to like focus on like a
podcast or something and he was just
hysterically laughing and then he'd go
to crying
and it was he was just hammered so it
was interesting like I'm [__] high
right now no he was anytime you get on
the train lead there's gonna be I love
it drama I love I love that about uh
Boston New York's a little bit more New
York I could never figure out the system
because I've only been there a few times
and there's Express trains and [__] like
that and there's too many lines so
there's an a train and that's all the
Broadway type deal okay then there's the
express that's from 178th Street
I think it just takes you right down to
like if you're going under don't quote
me on this 125th or maybe 70 seconds I
don't know I don't think I ever went
that high that's like hardly that's what
I'm saying right that's all I'm up there
but uh you know they have like the
number one and all that [__] the Queens
I don't know don't quote me on this
anybody I don't know the the trains
anymore I don't remember that that was a
long time ago but I always had fun for
me it was a bus growing up oh yeah for
me I rode a bus I said it's like a
school bus or like a city bus like a
city bus okay and it was a straight line
it was number one or I went from New
York to New Jersey or vice versa that's
how I traveled in those days you know
two bucks to get you into the city
you stop your little bottle of
blackberry Brandy maybe a [__] eight
pack of beer
put on the bus nobody was saying unto
those days a 20 minute ride you drink
three beers a couple shots of blackberry
Brandy you're in the city tuned up
already
but you know it's just uh
it's what you could get away with and
what you could do you're not gonna get
on the train drunk and drink but you're
gonna do a little shots or something
you're gonna put it in something yeah it
doesn't look like the obvious what was
your what was your go-to
uh Gatorade really yeah vodka and
Gatorade vodka and then when you get a
little bit more money you get the wolf
Schmidt whatever the [__] that is the
silver label that's why I can't drink
Vodka anymore because those plastic chug
or jugs we had as kids that like that
someone wouldn't buy or something they
were disgusting tasted like paint
thinner I can't do vodka anymore
yeah you gotta get yourself out of that
[__] one guy you gotta ask her now is
it gonna be men there no not really it's
all mine oh my God [__] women talking
about what I'm sitting in like a [__]
Momo looking around thinking about a gun
have a girlfriend another girl used to
take me to those things
let's go out with my friends get them in
six [__] women at the table and
you're like what the [__] do I do yeah
and I'd always get like a call I don't
even know I'd always get myself out of
it I [__] make something up I gotta
go I gotta call my friend in Jersey
maybe he's gonna pick me up I'd always
do something [__] ridiculous
that's always been like my fear is
falling into that woman room like into
that [__] what do you think's gonna
happen just I'm gonna hear [__] I don't
want to [__] hear you get four or
three women together and you sit there
for more than eight minutes you'll want
to [__] shoot yourself I love women I
love but when you get three or four of
them in the room and they start talking
about what's important to them and [__]
you you you will fall off your [__]
chair in laughter and aggravate you want
to kick one of them like one of them
will start like one of them would just
break your [__] back yeah and you'll
like them whatever but when you get a
couple of them together longer than 20
minutes
you want to shoot yourself no disrespect
the women I love you but I'm just
telling you how it is what the what the
world on this street is I just love the
way you put it they start talking about
what's important to them yeah like
whatever the [__] they talk about the
store whatever the [__] you know and you
sit there and going wow how do I end up
here what the [__] did I do to deserve
this story you start thinking about
torture like what people Define this toy
to like I'll mess up your [__] oh
he's sitting here listening to this [__]
for an hour which is worse to you hummus
up the [__] or six women at the sushi
dinner I'll tell you what [__] it I
didn't know how much what bothers me to
no end
cotton in my [__] mouth
like I can't wait to touch a cotton at
all except when it's wiping my [__]
that's it I don't like cotton play
cotton balls cotton or gauze yeah like
yeah I did a [__] dentist put gauze
in my mouth when he was doing a root
canal
that bothered me more than needles
[__] everything yeah I don't like it
has a weird texture yeah I don't like
cotton close to me in my mouth and my
[__] head it drives me [__] nuts
you understand me I don't know why this
drives me [__] nuts did you get high
before the broken him
sure
man I got blasted like 7 15 like a
[__] that's always my fear I
don't like I feel like pain would be
super intense on weed not animals it is
the problem if you take the gas
you might go to a weird place
what the [__] is what the [__] is that
sons of Anarchy's outside Austin there's
white people shooting [__] black
people cops I can't breathe what the
[__]
I don't [__] I don't [__] know I
can't breathe I don't [__] know you
ordered one of those shirts yet so you
can walk around and show solidarity no
there's no solidarity you know I mean
what do you want me to tell you that's
[__] up though after the cops getting
killed no please if this is a complete
the best is oh we're gonna put body
cameras on you can show up with the the
oh they had everything but a [__]
camera crew on that thing when they
jumped and they choked that black guy
yeah yeah everything but a [__]
camera crew bro they're going through
the [__] floor that's murder
that's murder in any other [__] City
would you invite on murder there yes you
[__] would yeah that's murder I saw
it you saw it but they had they're the
[__] power Supreme now they're gonna
dig themselves into a [__] hole Yeah
now we started now I think I got copycat
and every year we go through a trend
three years ago was the children going
[__] bananas at schools and morons
blowing themselves up in movie theaters
and [__] you know I'm trying to watch
Batman and this guy wants to be [__]
Clint Eastwood all of a [__] sudden I
need this [__] mostly they take a
picture of me it's like Bozo the [__]
clown obviously somebody sat him down
smacked them gave him a pill and sent
them to the movie theater loaded to the
gills like Rambles they shoot everybody
in there you're on a mission from Satan
you know that poor kid is half [__]
you can't tell that poor kid's half
[__] yeah he's somebody sent him
[__] down [__] slapped him told
martians were gonna stick a grenade up
his ass to go shoot the [__] movie to
that poor kid you know you could tell so
somebody else is going to strike down
out and start shooting [__] cops let
me ask you something
I I have dear friends of the cops I grew
up with a lot of cops I as a criminal
I've never had a B for the cop you'll
never hear me on on the podcast or
anything call a cop a derogatory name
that's why I've always had that attitude
that's why I've never had that problem
with police officers there was one cop
in my 51 years on this planet that I had
a problem with and that was the cop that
got assigned on the valet kidnapping me
and him went back and forth
look you came to your house and told you
they were coming for you and stuff no no
no not that one this was a guy that took
his job a little bit too [__]
seriously
and I'm the Villa kidnapping he became
you know Johnny Saint on the scene
he looked at it from a different
perspective he didn't look at it from
anybody's perspective he had a different
outlook on it
which I forget what the [__] it was he
had the Outlook that you guys were
scumbags when you took this guy down and
there was no drugs involved he was
trying to rob him
there was just no trace of drugs there
was a scale that was cleaned off
and there was like other paraphernalia
but there was no proof of the [__]
drugs so they they were saying no you
guys tried to Rob them and that was his
intent from day one this guy but this
guy didn't let up on me at all even
after I went away to prison and I came
back for the community service hearing
he was there
and he was going against me all the
[__] went
and there was a couple times we had just
verbal exchanges you know he was a big
guy but I hate him that much and he
hated me you know his hate for me in
turn made me [__] hate him because I
knew you know yeah but besides that I
never really had a problem with any
[__] cop no I mean this town but it's
it does help when people take their jobs
too seriously like I waited in line it
for 30 minutes today at UPS what the
[__] happened to you by your words UPS
what the [__] were you doing at UPS for
30 minutes because I had a gift that I
had was gonna get delivered and I I
wasn't at my house because you can't
wear your house from 8 AM to 8pm and I
went to go pick it up Saturday but they
wouldn't give it to me so I had to go
back today why didn't they give it to
you Saturday they said even though I
called the 800 number I didn't put a
formal request to get the package
so I came back it's just bureaucracy
like a [__] and then they
weren't gonna give it to me because my
ID doesn't have my new address on it and
I I was so I was this close to like
ripping their computers and throwing it
on the wall I I was fuming but it just
it's uh
I worked a lot or I looked I worked
three or four retail jobs and restaurant
jobs for five or six years it's tough
stop dealing with the public very tough
but the thing I'll say is I think
they're going to run into an issue
asking for a 15 minimum an hour wage
minimum wage because I don't think a lot
of these people working there deserve 15
an hour so they're going to lose their
jobs
because a lot of these people are just
it's it's beyond ups every everywhere I
was at Target today I was at CVS today
and I don't know if they're over the
service
has gone down horrifically in this
country like [__] they judge
everything by labor versus Workforce
they might you know everything is done
by a [__] formula you walk into I
listen I do all my business with CVS the
only reason why I go to CBS is I love
the two girls
and it isn't their fault
it isn't their fault yeah that's true
they got two girls working there one is
filling prescriptions the other one is
taking prescriptions and picking them up
and giving them the people I breaking
down the prescription to drinking with
two every four hours what's that four
every two hours no two every four hours
oh my God I need glasses well we'll talk
about late you know it's two [__]
hours right it's tough and the phone's
ringing Pharmacy line one Pharmacy line
two Pharmacy when I go to CVS now I
prepare for a 25 minute wait right I
worked at CVS for two years I grabbed in
I get what I got to do my nasal [__] the
[__] Visine for the reefer I I get
whatever else I need taped from my wrist
but Jiu-Jitsu whatever the [__] I need I
stand online I just take the beating so
when I get there that's it and it
bothers me because the front counter has
the Chiclets the bite size like a
[__] I need one package of those
to get me straight once a week and I'm
good you know what I'm saying there's a
gas station on Laurel Canyon by your
house yeah they gums and wait on The
Comedy Store I pull over there and get
one package before my sense it sets me
straight some people do steroids some
people do drugs before their sets I pop
those little [__] little Chiclets you
love gum you have like a gum by the
liquor store that we go to the Mexican
gum the full on the thing I love that
and then on the way down to San Diego
you put an entire pack when I'm [__]
stoned to the gills and I'm driving I'm
falling asleep I got a pack of gumbo and
it works the [__] jaw like a hooker
giving 10 [__]
[Music]
foreign